Republicans and Democrats put together
the largest spending bill in the history
of the world president Trump suggests
reopening the American economy by Easter
and new data emerges suggesting some
good news on coronavirus I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
protect your data from prying eyes and
expressvpn calm slash been not kidding
about that lots of hackers out there
expressvpn dot-com / been ok so lot of
big news happening in the world of
coronavirus which is the only news on
planet earth at this point obviously the
biggest news of course is that very very
late last night like early morning the
White House in Congress did strike a
deal to deliver 2 trillion dollars in
government relief to a nation
increasingly under lockdown according to
the New York Times that 2 trillion
dollars in relief is only part of the
spending here the fact is that this
which is the biggest is it's not bail
out but the biggest spending plan in the
history of the world I mean not just the
United States and the history of the
world is only part of the deal here the
Treasury is also floating about four
trillion dollars in spending with regard
to buying up commercial paper buying a
bank loans and all of the rest so what
exactly is in this giant rescue bill
well a lot a lot so according to first
of all I think it's important to note
here that Nancy Pelosi to the last
minute was insisting that her holding
this thing up over the weekend was a
good idea
hey the Speaker of the House Nancy
Pelosi she was on TV yesterday
suggesting that the bill should have
been held up over environmental concerns
of all things and great legislative
leadership hear from Nancy Pelosi
basically we ends up with effectively a
very very close cousin to the to the
deal that was rejected several times on
Monday by the Democrats here was Nancy
Pelosi just before the passage of this
deal insisting the deal had to include
environmental protections because I
don't know about you but when the entire
world economy is on the brink of
complete and utter disaster the thing I
am worried most about is forcing
Airlines to lower their carbon emissions
who is Nancy Pelosi last night being an
idiot I do think that there is a whole
concern in our country that if we're
giving tens of billions of dollars to
the airlines that
we could least have a shared value about
what what happens to the environment but
that is it
you know that is an excuse not a reason
for Senator McConnell go forward some of
the other issues like not fully
extending family medically not funding
food stamps I hope that will all change
in the next few hours but there are
issues that are central to the
well-being of America's family okay I
mean the priorities priorities the fact
that this person was described as
legislative master mind over the last
year is insane to me
a person who surrendered to the squad
and then proceeded to run a botched
impeachment attempt and then for no
reason it all held up a rescue package
by the way it was the prospect of the
passage of that rescue package that led
to the single greatest jump in Dow Jones
Industrial Average in the history of the
Dow Jones Industrial Average yesterday
jumped over 2,000 points well right now
at this hour
we're still waiting from Nancy fer Nancy
Pelosi's go ahead she said that the new
bipartisan agreement quote takes us a
long way down the road in meeting the
needs of the American people but she
didn't endorse it said House Democrats
will now view the final provisions and
legislative text of the agreement to
determine a course of action so she's
still gumming up the works at least a
little bit but this thing appears to be
a foregone conclusion at this point so
what exactly is in this thing well
they're a bunch of major spending
provisions obviously the New York Times
has a rundown of some of the big
provisions they say the government will
send direct payments to taxpayers
lawmakers have agreed to provide 1,200
bucks and direct payments to taxpayers
with incomes up to 75,000 dollars per
year by the way it's an insane provision
that Democrats basically made it that if
you make over $75,000 per year you're
gonna have to pay that back to the
government so the government destroyed
your job the government destroyed your
business and now the government's gonna
sign you a check with the proviso that
you have to pay it back if you make more
than $75,000 per year by the way those
are the people who make seventy five
thousand dollars per year or probably in
the long term going to be hit the
hardest not because they're the ones
making the most the least money
obviously they're people who are making
less money because those are the ones
who are gonna see the greatest gap
between what they were making and what
they are currently making namely the
difference between $100,000 and zero as
opposed to a person who is already on
food stamps or welfare or a person who's
already on unemployment or person whose
salary may drop from $60,000 to $35,000
if you drop from $75,000 to zero that is
actually a bigger drop now again that
doesn't mean that poor people don't
deserve the money people who are poor do
deserve the money but the point is that
people who are running the businesses
are the people who are hiring the poor
people and a lot of those people are now
being floated basically zero interest
loans that are non forgivable according
to the federal let sprit this way if the
Republicans had proposed this everybody
would be up in arms Democrats proposed
it so of course it's no big deal at all
families would receive five hundred
bucks per child in an attempt to create
a safety net for people whose jobs and
businesses are affected by the pandemic
by the way you get no money none if you
earn more than ninety nine thousand
dollars a year so you get twelve hundred
bucks in direct payments up to seventy
five thousand dollars if you earn
seventy five thousand dollars last year
which by the way that's not what you're
earning this year not in this economy so
that means testing this stuff is very
bizarre okay and ending for people who
earn more than ninety nine thousand
dollars a year at all so if you earned a
hundred thousand dollars you and your
spouse then presumably you make nothing
you go home with zero unemployment
benefits do grow substantially they go
to many more Americans lawmakers agreed
it's a significant expansion of
unemployment benefits that would extend
jobless insurance by thirteen weeks and
include a four month enhancement of
benefits that is not a grave change from
over the weekend over the weekend the
Republicans were already proposing three
months of extension of jobless insurance
and enhancement of benefits it has moved
up by one month emma-crats wanted it to
be six months really Democrats wanted it
to be permanent the program was
broadened to include freelancers
furloughed employees and gig workers
such as uber drivers so you know that
those people need to make money as well
obviously it's gonna be kind of hard to
tamp down exactly how much money those
people were making in the first place
small business will receive emergency
loans but only if they keep their
workers so if you're a small business
and you're preparing for the future and
you're saying to yourself okay we're not
gonna have the same customer base two
months from now that we do now which is
obviously true then you have to keep
your workers in order to receive the
loan in the first place which again is a
bizarre situation because it just means
mass layoffs in two months instead of
everybody being laid off right now and
then receiving unemployment benefits and
then being rehired as appropriate
instead we are now forcing companies to
continue to pay their employees who will
then be hired at the first moment that
that is available the bill provides
federally guaranteed loans available at
community banks to small businesses that
pledge to not lay off their workers the
loans would be available during an
emergency
ending June 30th and would be forgiven
if the employer continues to pay workers
for the duration of the crisis but it's
unclear exactly how the duration of the
crisis is defined exactly
senator Rubio worked with Democrats to
create this program said the goal is to
keep employees connected to their
employers so that people aren't just
having to stay home and aren't just
feeling the stress of being laid off but
the uncertainty of whether they'll even
have a job to go back to but this
doesn't alleviate that because again the
minute that all of these restrictions
are off and we go back to the world in
in somewhat regular fashion those jobs
are not going to exist any more I mean
let's be real about this if you're in
the cruise line industry and you're
taking a bailout to keep all of your
cruise line employees employed over the
next two months do you really think
those people are gonna be employed in
month three the answer of course is no
they're not going to be employed in
month three because at that point I mean
they're gonna get fired right I mean the
cruise industry is gonna go the way the
dodo bird at least for several years
here distressed companies can receive
government bailouts they're not bailouts
guys if you shut down a company and then
you pay the company that's not a bailout
but distressed companies can receive
government money with strings attached
loans for distressed companies would
come from a four hundred twenty five
billion dollar fund controlled by the
Federal Reserve an additional 75 billion
would be available for industry specific
loans including to Airlines and hotels
by the way that was sort of pretty much
what was in the weekend belt the
Democrats weren't whining about the
creation of the Federal Reserve fund was
one of the chief sticking points and
negotiations because people were worried
about the 2008 Wall Street bailout
Democrats pressed for immediate
disclosure of recipients and stronger
oversight including installing an
inspector general and congressionally
appointed board to monitor it which
again I don't have any problem with
companies that benefit could not engage
in stock buybacks while receiving
government assistance and for an
additional year after that okay I have a
question about the additional year after
that it's one thing to say no stock
buybacks cuz we're trying to keep people
employed right now if you're worried
about the stock market
you idiots you're gonna need companies
to buy back their own stock if they feel
that their stock is undervalued and
that's all the stock buyback is if your
company is being undervalued on the open
market and you wish to regain more
control of your company one of the
things that you're going to have to do
is buy back stock
okay particularly in a in a situation
where the stock market is falling
precipitously one 401 K is to go back up
you're gonna need Amazon to be able to
buy back its own stock Democrats also
secured a provision ensuring that
Trump's family businesses or those of
any other senior government officials
cannot receive loan money
through the fun okay so question why are
Trump's employees worse than other
employees it is one thing if he's
getting exorbitant money I mean we're
gonna see that through disclosure rules
but I'm just wondering why Trump is
being singled out this way or by the way
anybody else who's employed by a
business that is connected it's one of
the Senators or Congress people there
are a lot of employees who are working
for businesses that are tangentially
connected to members of Congress
hey hospitals would receive aid the
agreement includes a hundred billion
dollars for hospitals and healthcare
systems across the nation and that of
course was going to be in the bill
already can we're gonna get to more of
what was in the bill also we're gonna
get to the latest on coronavirus
generally there is some good news
possibly there's also some bad news
because this is the the situation in
which we now live there is no real good
news until we get our arms around this
thing we'll get to more of this in just
one second first let's talk about
keeping your home safe right now so they
have heard news recently that lots of
local law enforcement agencies are just
letting people out of jail like they're
seriously afraid of coronavirus and so
they are letting people out of jail who
have committed crimes and those people
are wandering around and many of them
will go back to committing crimes
wouldn't it be good for you to protect
your property at this time especially
since you are probably on your property
it's good to know what's happening on
your property and this is why you need
ring-ring gives you protection at every
corner helps you create custom
affordable security for your home ring
detects motion when people come on your
property rings video doorbells let you
answer the door check in on your home
anytime from anywhere ring helps you
stay connected to your home anywhere in
the world so if there's a package
delivery a surprise visitor you're gonna
get an alert and be able to see hear and
speak to them all from your phone I've
always been paranoid about security now
more than ever and this is why I have
ring devices all over my house I mean
I'm making sure that my property is safe
and secure at all time I have three
small children I want to know what's
going on here all the time and that's
why I have ring got a special offer on
the ring welcome kit when you go to ring
comm slash been the welcome kit includes
the ring video doorbell two and chime
Pro it's all you need to start building
custom security for your home today just
go to ring comm slash BAM that is
ring.com slash then okay so the senate
is also poised to approve some three
hundred fifty billion dollars in loans
to small business in an effort to keep
Americans on payrolls a major challenge
in the negotiations was that five
hundred billion dollars that's according
to The Wall Street Journal the Treasury
Secretary will have the authority to
directly lend a slice of those funds
so not much change over the weekend it
was just a Nancy Pelosi held this thing
up for basically no reason because we're
always going to tack on more spending
after this meanwhile in other financial
news US 3-month Treasuries have now
dipped below zero we now have negative
interest rates on three-month Treasury
bonds which is to say that the demand
for bonds in the short term is
extraordinarily high also the Federal
Reserve is currently attempting to push
banks to lend the way they do that is
basically by charging banks to stow
their money with the Federal Reserve
they're telling them don't show your
money here all right go lends it out the
problem is no I mean beyond the beyond
the obvious which is making sure that
people who are already in hock because
of the current shutdown don't get
foreclosed upon don't don't have their
loans recalled aside from that who's
lending money to start a business at
this point who's gonna start a business
in this in this climate I mean very very
difficult to imagine a lot of people who
are looking to take out new loans from
banks to start a business for example
the problem right now is that the
underlying economic issue is in fact the
virus itself and that is not going to be
healed so the government has done at
this point basically what it appears it
can do to hold everything in place for
the moment now the question becomes
what's the next step how do we get out
of all of this how do we move beyond
what is going on right now and key to
that question is gonna be how fast to
get our arms around coronavirus itself
there is an open debate that is breaking
out right now about just how deadly
kovat 19 is okay and that open debate is
worth having because again the data that
we have are insufficient and we have to
determine exactly what the risk levels
are so we can determine exactly how fast
people can go to work how fast we can
resolution from a sort of Chinese
lockdown style to South Korean style
with heavy testing and people working if
they are healthy how fast we can get a
test that is available to check your
antibodies to see if you already had
coronavirus and now you're immune to the
virus itself and so we bottom line is
that we are short on data as data comes
in then we are going to know more about
how fast we can get people back to work
at this point as I said there may be
some good news and there may not be some
good news and we just don't know at this
point so for the sort of pessimistic
view on how deadly this virus is there's
a professor in Britain named Hugh
Montgomery and he put out a viral video
explaining how deadly corona virus is
the
this professor is an intensive care
specialist based in London here is how
he explained how deadly the pandemic
could be normal flu if I get that I'm
gonna infect on average about 1.3 1.4
people okay if there was such a division
yeah and if those 1.3 1.4 people gave it
to the next lot that's the second time
it gets passed on but it's on that's
happened ten times I've been responsible
for about 14 1 4 cases of flu this
coronavirus is very very infectious so
every person passes it to three now that
doesn't sound like much of a difference
but in each of those three pass suit to
three and the happens of ten layers I
have been responsible for infecting 59
thousand people okay so the question is
now at number one the infection rate and
the nd and the second question is what
is the death rate so in order to
determine the death rate the question is
not how many people have died versus how
many people have tested positive the
question is how many people have died
compared to how many people have it and
that's a question we just don't know the
answer to at this point and the reason
that we don't know the answer to that at
this point is because so many people are
asymptomatic have had corona virus and
they move beyond corona virus may
already be immune to corona virus there
are a couple of articles today that are
that they talk specifically about this
question one is from an Oxford study
there's an Oxford study that just came
out so everybody has been has been
citing a different study the Imperial
College study from Britain that suggests
there to be like 2.2 million deaths in
the United States if we just allowed
everybody to run out and associate with
one another there's another study that
has now come out modeling by researchers
at the University of Oxford and the team
at Oxford's evolutionary ecology of
infectious disease lab says that half of
the UK may have already been infected
with corona virus okay well that'd
actually be good news everybody's
freaking out oh well my god that's
that's correct no that would be good
news because the number of dead people
compared with the number of people or
people a number of people in ICU is
compared with the number of people who
haven't in Britain would then be a much
much smaller number right the death
rates would look if now if this were the
case the death rates in Britain would
look more like the flu and less like the
sort of 1.3 percent death rate that
we're seeing in the United States or the
10% death rate that we are seeing in
Italy if the modelling is confirmed in
follow-up studies this
to New York magazine that mean fewer
than point zero one percent of those
infected require hospital treatment with
a majority showing very minor symptoms
or none at all according to this
modeling the corona virus arrived in
mid-january at the latest and spread
undetected for over a month before the
first cases were confirmed based on us
assess the susceptibility infected
recovery model a commonly used estimate
in epidemiology with data from case and
death reports in the UK and Italy the
researchers determined that the initial
herd immunity strategy of the UK
government actually could have been
sound meaning they were saying let
everybody out let everybody infect each
other then we have herd immunity I'm
surprised there's been such unqualified
acceptance of the Imperial model said
lead researcher sue Netra Gupta
referring to an academic report
predicting up to 250,000 people in
Britain could be killed if the
government maintained its plan to
suppress the virus but not get rid of it
completely as in Monday 87 people in the
UK had died from coronavirus out of a
total of 90,000 436 tests some 8,000
were positive the Oxford team is now
working with researchers at the
universities of Cambridge and Kent to
begin antibody testing as soon as this
week once there's antibody testing we're
gonna know whether a lot of people have
had this and are already immune which is
gonna be an enormous enormous change to
the data that this will allow us to know
exactly how dangerous this virus is
because we are operating we're flying
blind a little bit as to how dangerous
the virus is based on people who go in
for tests are the people most likely to
have symptoms people most likely to have
symptoms are the people most likely to
go to the ICU people will go to the ICU
or the people most likely to die so you
have this very very filtered system
where the only people who are testing
positive are the ones who are going in
for the test but this is asymptomatic so
it's possible a huge percentage of
people have this this is not the only
article on this topic today and this
would be hopeful news what you want
right now is lots of people to have
already had this and not even known
right that is best case scenario is
tonnes of people already have it already
walking around with it are already
immune and we didn't even know about it
that'd be best case scenario we're gonna
get two more possible good news on
coronavirus in just one second because
these economic problems they're not
gonna be healed right we can hold we can
hold place we can tread water for the
moment we can't do it forever right we
can't have the fed floating negative
interest rates
forever without the dollar being
completely undermined and people
starting to lose faith in the Full Faith
and Credit of the United States if there
has to be an underlying economy for
people to borrow on the back of
otherwise you basically have
government's just borrowing from each
other and that right there is is
essentially a Ponzi scheme okay
get two more of the possible the news in
just one second first let us talk about
the fact that if there's something wrong
with your car you probably want to order
parts online instead of going into a
store right now those stores are
probably not even opening I mean we got
we got to be engaged in social
distancing and be at home anyway so why
exactly would you not order a part from
rockauto.com you should do this Eve
money hand go to a store but certainly
when you can rockauto.com is your best
case solution rockauto.com has all the
parts you're going to need the specific
part for your car they have the same
prices for specialists and for members
of the general public and they make it
really quick and really easy also the
prices are fantastic the rockauto.com
catalog is unique remarkably easy to
navigate they always offer the lowest
price as possible rather than changing
prices based on what the market will
bear for example the Delphi FG 1456 fuel
pump assembly for the 2005 to 2010 Honda
Odyssey is 353 bucks and 99 cents at
advance it's only 216 bucks in 79 cents
rockauto.com so you're gonna get it
cheaper you're gonna get a better part
then the sort of generic part that you
might have to get off-the-shelf
rockauto.com is a family business
definitely worth supporting in these
times go to rockauto.com right now see
all the parts available for your car or
truck right shapiro in there how did you
hear about us box so they know that we
say you go to Rock Auto calm right now
see all of those parts right this very
instant okay so as I say it's not just
the Oxford study suggesting that there
may be tons and tons and tons of people
out there who have this thing and don't
even know it there there are two doctors
professors of medicine at Stanford one
his name's Aaron Ben's ovide and another
one is Jay Bhattacharya and they have a
piece in The Wall Street Journal called
is the corona virus as deadly as they
say they say fear of kovin 19 is based
on high estimated case fatality rate 2%
to 4% of people with confirmed covered
19 have died according to the w-h-o and
others so if 100 million Americans
ultimately get the disease 2 million to
4 million could die we believe that
estimate is deeply flawed the true
fatality rate is the portion of those
infected who die not the deaths from
identified positive cases right what
I've been saying right here it is not
the question is not how many people died
over how many people have been tested
positive the question is how many people
died over how many people have this
thing period or have had it in in the
last couple of months the degree of bias
is uncertain because available data are
limited it could make the difference
between an epidemic that kills 20,000
and one that kills two million people
if the number of actual infections is
much larger than the number of cases
then the true fatality rate is much
lower that's not only plausible but
likely say these two professors of
medicine at Stanford population samples
from China Italy Iceland in the US
provide relevant evidence on or around
January 31st country sent planes to
evacuate citizens from Wuhan China when
those planes landed the passengers were
tested for covin 19 in quarantine after
14 days the percentage who tested
positive was 0.9% if this was the
prevalence in the greater Wu Han area On
January 31st then with a population of
about 20 million greater Wuhan about had
178,000 infections about 30 fold more
than the number of reported cases
they're saying that people who are
flying let's say that those people are
representative of the general Han
population by the way it is likely the
data actually under representative of
the generalizable Han population because
those are the people who can afford to
leave the country and come back to other
countries the fatality rate according to
these stats would be tenfold lower than
the estimates based on reported cases
next the northeastern Italian town of
Voe near the provincial capital of Padua
on March 6th all 3,300 people in BO were
tested 9 you were positive
that's a prevalence of 2.7 percent if
you apply that prevalence to the whole
province which has about a million
people which had 198 reported cases that
means there were actually 26,000
infections at the time that's more than
130 fold the number of actual reported
cases since Italy's case fatality rate
of 8 percent is estimated using
confirmed cases the real fatality rate
would not be 8 percent it would be point
0 6 percent which is actually lower than
the flu fatality rate the flu fatality
rate is 0.1% in Iceland decode genetics
is working with the government to
perform widespread testing say these
columnist for The Wall Street Journal
and professors of medicine at Stanford
in a sample of nearly 2,000 entirely
asymptomatic people researchers
estimated disease prevalence of just
over 1% Iceland's first case was
reported on February 28th weeks behind
the u.s. it's plausible that the
proportion of the US population that has
been infected is double triple even ten
times as high as the estimates from
Iceland that also implies a dramatically
lower fatality rate they say the best
albeit very weak evidence in the u.s.
comes from the NBA between March 11th
and 19th a substantial number of NBA
players and teams receive testing by
March 19th 10 out of 450 rostered
players were positive since not everyone
was tested that represents a lower bound
on the prevalence of 2.2% meaning 10
of the 450 rostered players were
positive but it probably is a much
larger number the NBA isn't a
representative population contact among
players may have facilitated
transmission but we have extend the
lower bound assumption to cities with
NBA teams like like Memphis or something
we get nine hundred ninety thousand
infections in the United States the
number of cases reported in the u.s. was
thirteen thousand six hundred seventy
seven seventy two fold lower these
numbers imply a fatality rate from Kovan
nineteen orders of magnitude smaller
than it appears so how can we reconcile
these estimates with epidemiology Mia
logical models say these colonists first
the test used to identify cases doesn't
catch people who are infected and
recovered because it's not an antibody
test second testing rates were woefully
low for a long time and typically
reserved for the severely ill together
these facts imply that the confirmed
cases are likely orders of magnitude
less than the true number of infections
epidemiological modelers haven't
adequately adapted their estimates to
account for these factors at all
they say the epidemic started in China
sometime in November or December the
first confirmed u.s. cases included a
person who traveled from Wuhan January
15th it's likely the virus was here
before that because tens of thousands of
people were travelling from Wuhan to the
United States in December existing
evidence says that this thing is really
really transmissible an epidemic seed on
January 1st implies that by March 9th
about six million people in the United
States would have been infected as of
March 23rd according to the Centers for
Disease Control and Prevention
there were 499 kovin 19 deaths in the
u.s. if six million cases is accurate
that's a mortality rate of 0.01 percent
which is 1/10 the mortality rate of the
flu this doesn't mean that kovin 19 is a
non-issue
it could be overwhelmed you could have
20 to 40,000 deaths but that sort of
epidemic is far less severe problem than
one that kills around 2 million right it
means higher infection rate but also
much lower death rate and you end up
with numbers that actually do look like
the American flu according to these
comments now again the data here are
insufficient we just don't know whether
this is true or not but everyone
literally everyone is saying there are
many more infected people that have been
tested I mean that is perfectly obvious
there are many many more infected people
than have been tested the antibody tests
are not ready so what that would suggest
is that it's quite possible you've
already had corona virus and you got
over it or you had it you never knew you
had it or you had it you didn't know you
had it and now you're fine right in
other words the number of people who are
dying or ending up in the ICU come
the actual number not the testing number
the actual number of people who have had
coronavirus is actually an
extraordinarily low percentage that is a
serious possibility so we're gonna wait
for more data on that as I say I don't
know the hardest three words to say in
the English language I don't know you
don't know nobody knows and to pretend
that we absolutely know that s rates is
just it's ridiculous because we don't
okay we don't so for anybody who's out
there saying this thing is significantly
more deadly than the flu and we know it
for certain okay we know for certain
that it's overwhelming the health care
system in Italy we know it's
overwhelming the health care system in
Spain we know it's a risk to overwhelm
the health care system in New York we do
not know the actual death rate of this
virus right now now it doesn't mean we
shouldn't be panicked or it doesn't you
should be concerned at the very least it
does mean that when all the information
comes out it's gonna be fascinating to
see what exactly the actual death and
infection rates were of this particular
disease okay we're gonna give you some
more good news in just one second this
isn't possible than it is this is actual
actual good news we're gonna get to that
in just one second first let's talk
about the fact that everybody needs life
insurance it's just the responsible
thing to do no matter what your
situation the fact is that there's one
thing that is inevitable in life and
that is death and that is why you should
be prepared for your family to be able
to supplement their income in case god
forbid something should happen to you
and this is why you need to go over to
policy genius
right now policy genius makes finding
the right life insurance a breeze in
minutes you can compare quotes from top
insurers and find your best price you
could save fifteen hundred bucks or more
every year by using policy genius to
compare life insurance policies when
once you apply the policy genius team
will handle all the paperwork and the
red tape for free and policy genius
doesn't just make life insurance easy
they can also help you find the right
home auto disability insurance so if you
don't know what's just around the corner
that's okay be prepared for anything
with life insurance in just a few
minutes you can find your best price and
apply at policy genius com policy genius
because you never know what the future
is going to hold and that is why you
should ensure against it by the way
again they do all sorts of insurance
they do the auto insurance the
disability insurance that can bundle
home and auto they'll do it all for you
quickly and easily and handle all the
red tape and paperwork policy genius
everybody gets the future wrong better
to get life insurance right policy
genius.com
okay another piece of good news The
Washington Post is reporting that the
corona virus is not mutating
significantly as it circulates through
the human population very good news
Hevy mutations in coronavirus would mean
that a vaccine develop do not actually
be supremely effective because it's
moved on to a different strain
scientists are closely studying the
novel's the novel pathogens pathogens
genetic code say that this thing is not
mutating significantly that relative
stability suggests the virus is less
likely to become more or less dangerous
as it spreads and represents encouraging
news for researchers hoping to create a
long-lasting vaccine all viruses do
evolve over time but this thing seems to
be a dumb virus in the sense it is not
acquiring information all that fast
the new corona virus has proofreading
machinery and that reduces the error
rate and thus the pace of mutation it
looks pretty much the same everywhere
and thus it is not adapting to local
populations and becoming more and more
deadly SARS Cova - the virus that causes
the disease covin 19 is similar to
corona viruses that circulate naturally
in bats
it probably jumped through a penguin
which people have been eating don't eat
the dam's bats and penguins and it's not
culturally insensitive you idiots just
don't do it I don't care if you're white
green or blue do not eat the damned
Penguins how many times we have to do
this my god scientists are now studying
more than a thousand different samples
of the virus Peter Thiel and a molecular
geneticist at Johns Hopkins University
Applied Physics Laboratory who's been
studying the virus told The Washington
Post there are only about four to ten
genetic differences between the strains
that had infected people in the US and
the original virus that spread in wuhan
that is very good news an other piece of
good news the FDA is now accelerating a
lot of the treatments that are becoming
available to the general public which is
good I mean there are a lot of people
who literally need treatment like right
now or you know being treated with
ventilators or in grave condition and
they need a treatment right now the FDA
has begun to allow doctors to treat some
patients with the blood plasma of
patients who have recovered from corona
virus caused Kovan 19 disease the
treatment must be approved on a
case-by-case basis
patients have to meet certain conditions
according to the FDA the treatment is
considered investigational based on the
possibility that convalescent plasma a
portion of whole blood from recovered
victims may contain antibodies to the
virus that may be effective against the
infection so we have the same blood type
and the person has recovered from
coronavirus you grab some of their blood
put it in your body now their blood is
carrying the antibodies to fight off the
infection is the idea the agency
stressed convalescent plasma has not
been shown to be effective and every
disease studied the plan is for clinical
studies of the procedure to begin one of
the hard things about clinical studies
in the midst of a pandemic is the
clinical studies generally require a
a compare a population a control
population of a population that is not
going to get the treatment how many
people are gonna volunteer to be part of
a study where they're the control
population if you're in serious trouble
the last thing you want to be is part of
the control population you want the
treatment the agency said it's taking
this unusual early step because of the
rapidly rising numbers of coronavirus
patients and deaths in the United States
blood plasma must be collected only from
people are eligible otherwise to give
blood so hopefully new treatments coming
about meanwhile we're hearing more and
more cases of prominent people with
corona virus there's a basketball player
on karl-anthony towns his mom apparently
is on a ventilator now and we know that
there is a person who worked for the New
York Times who passed away yesterday of
a corona virus there was also a famous
Broadway playwright who passed away he
was 81 he was in poor condition already
Prince Charles has tested positive for
komono virus
he'd been experiencing mild symptoms for
days otherwise his remain in good health
according to a statement released by the
princes official residence the Duchess
of Cornwall has been tested but does not
have the virus that be referring to
Prince Charles's wife both are now self
isolating in their home in Scotland it's
not clear exactly when he caught it or
how he caught it but prominent people
are going to get this thing and most of
these problem people are recovering
right I mean we mote that the vast
majority on Hank and his wife recovered
Prince Charles will likely recover that
that is some good news and again that
goes back to what are the actual death
rates here versus sort of the
assumptions we're making about tests
done versus the number of people who
actually died from that now meanwhile
this does not mean that you can't
overwhelm the system by two things can
be true at once one the death rate is a
lot lower than we think it is and two
there are so many cases that the system
gets overwhelmed anyway right if the
death rate is the same as the flu 0.1%
but you're getting five times as many
people who are getting the disease that
means the system can easily build over
whelmed that's what you're seeing in
Spain and Italy Spain has now surpassed
China's death toll from the new corona
virus according to The Wall Street
Journal India has implemented the
world's most extensive stay at home
order Wednesday 1.3 billion people
locked down in India I don't even know
how you're going to enforce that because
so many people there are gravely
impoverished how do they even get food
absolutely unclear health officials in
Spain reported 738 fatalities from Kovan
19 the pneumonia like illness caused by
the virus which is the steepest daily
increase on a national death toll that
has risen to 33 434 sir
passing china's italy is leading by
leaps and bounds they've got almost
7,000 reported deaths in italy and again
they have very high mortality rate from
identified cases and as i keep repeating
over now i'm gonna keep repeating it the
because it makes a difference to you as
an individual your chances of life after
acquiring coronavirus by pretty much all
available data are a lot better than the
percentages you're seeing in the press
simply because the only percentage is
available based unavailable there are
the ones based on testing and testing is
not sufficient at this point here in the
united states we currently stand at 802
confirmed deaths from corona virus out
of fifty-five thousand two hundred and
forty-three confirmed cases of corona
virus in the united states
meanwhile in new york there's been a lot
of concern about an astronomical surge
the White House is expressing growing
alarm about the corona virus outbreak in
New York City advising people who have
passed through or left the city to place
themselves in 14th a quarantine dr.
deborah birx
pointed this out she says and so did
anthony foul she they said anyone who
leaves New York should be self
quarantined for 14 days at this point
you got to treat New York like it's
basically an epicenter of the disease
here are doctors Burch Burks and Falchi
talking about self quarantine to
everyone who has left New York over the
last few days because of the rate of the
number of cases you may have been
exposed before you left New York and I
think like governor de Santos has put
out today everybody who was in New York
should be self quarantine for the next
14 days to ensure that the virus doesn't
spread to others no matter where they
have gone whether it's Florida North
Carolina or out too far far reaches of
Long Island okay so obviously New York
City has has trouble we are starting to
see I mean New York by again by the
numbers is indeed an epicenter of this
virus if New York were country I believe
would be number five on the list of
places in which deaths have occurred
thanks to corona virus at this at this
point with that said obviously Andrew
Cuomo is is livid about this he says we
haven't flattened the curve everybody
keeps going out we got to stop this
thing here is the governor of New York
flatten the curve flatten the curve we
haven't sliding the curve
and the curve is actually increasing
that means the number of hospital beds
which is at 53,000 beds
3,000 ICU beds the anticipated need now
for the height of the curve is 140,000
hospital beds and approximately 40,000
intensive care unit beds i'm cuomo also
says you know when the federal
government says they're sending us for
that 400 ventilators and that's true
apparently they're sending more than
that but 400 ventilators is what my
Penza said he says we need 30,000
ventilators here's Cuomo complaining
about the lack of ventilators being
provided by the federal government FEMA
is sending us 400 ventilators these are
on the news this morning we are sending
400 ventilators to New York 400
ventilators I need 30,000 ventilators
you want a pat on the back for sending
400 ventilators what are we going to do
for 400 with 400 ventilators when we
need 30,000 ventilators you're missing
the magnitude of the problem and the
problem is defined by the magnitude okay
I just have one question so the media
have been treating Cuomo is that his
leadership has been absolutely stellar
in New York I'm just wondering what
exactly the leadership has constituted
that is vastly different from say gavin
newsom in california the only difference
that gavin newsom hasn't been widely
complaining about President Trump over
and over and over write the New York
Times has an article how says how Cuomo
once on the sidelines became the
politician of the moment with his
coronavirus briefings Governor Andrew
Cuomo has emerged as an authoritative
voice in the crisis I have a question
why a really serious question why like
his pressors are informative I don't
know that there any more informative
than the White House prep White House's
pressors all it seems to me is that the
media are very happy that Cuomo keeps
yelling at the White House but I'm just
wondering like he's the governor of a
state does he think that President Trump
should snaps his fingers and then the
ventilators magically appear
is anyone it's it's a it's a source of
grave irritation to me when members of
the media suggest that if only we just
did what Cuomo said we just nationalized
the factories that overnight Ford which
produces cars would start producing
hundreds of thousands
ventilators if only that Magic Man
Andrew Cuomo were in control of the
government and used the power of the
federal government ventilators would
magically begin appearing pop out of
nowhere
using the Star Trek replicator in New
York City hospitals that's not the way
any of this works and the fact that
Cuomo is shouting about this and asking
for more things and that Trump is giving
them as they come in I mean this is why
you see even Cuomo will basically say
this right on the one hand he'll say
what are they bragging about 400
ventilators we need more and then he'll
be like and yes they also give us
everything we need there's literally
video of him talking about like whenever
we talk with the feds they basically
give us what we ask for so far as they
are capable of doing so is my question
is why exactly is is Cuomo being hailed
as the quote-unquote politician of the
moment and why according to the New York
Times the governor repeatedly assailed
the federal response has slow
inefficient and inadequate far more
aggressively than he had before Cuomo
was once considered a bit player on the
national stage and abrasive presidents
who made a share of enemies among his
Democratic Party peers but now he is
emerging as the party's most prominent
voice in a time of crisis his briefings
articulate consistent often tinged with
empathy had become must-see television
so basically you like how he is on TV
and thus he is an authoritative voice
and thus he is a great leader
yeah I'm unaware of how his leadership
has radically changed things in New York
any differently again than Gavin Newsom
my idiot governor here in California has
radically changed things because he
hasn't I'm sorry he is not he he is
saying things and he is doing what any
normal governor would do under the
circumstances which is you try to get
the resources to your state but
complaining about President Trump is not
a strategy nor is it something that
fixes things it is not and there's I
guess there's this bizarre notion in the
media that Trump has like a bunch of
ventilators stored in the back room of
the White House then Trump is saying to
Cuomo ravaged it's nice to me I'll
release the ventilators and comes like
I'm not gonna be nice to you I'm not
gonna do that I mean that that's no
that's not what's going on here guys
we're trying to marshal the resources
and Cuomo yelling about it ain't gonna
change anything
meanwhile in New York some New York City
doctors are saying we're already at the
breaking point in terms of the number of
ICU beds available in terms of the
number of ventilators available it is
certainly true I asked my doctor wife
this yesterday it is certainly true that
the skit that if hospitals around the
country were prepared
for pandemic they would have had a lot
more ventilators on hand but nobody had
ever really thought that a pandemic like
this was going to come I mean it is a
sort of Black Swan event here's a New
York City doctor explaining we're
already at the breaking point in New
York City the reality is that what we're
seeing right now in our emergency rooms
is dire last week when I went to work we
talked about the one or two patients
amongst the dozens of others that might
have been a CO Veda coronavirus patient
this week in my shift yesterday nearly
every single patient that I took care of
was coronavirus and many of them
extremely severe many were put on
breathing tubes many decompensated quite
quickly there is a very different air
this week than there was last week and
quite honestly you know think about the
fact that our first New York City case
was on March 1st that's just over three
weeks ago to think that we'll be in any
place to lift these restriction or
measures by by Easter and just you know
in two or three weeks for me seems
completely magical thinking okay so
there obviously is a lot of alarm in New
York City there should be a lot of alarm
in New York City and again I don't know
how that like makes Cuomo gray leader or
anything but everybody's doing their
best look we're all muddling through and
that's basically the theme here now
President Trump for his part he is
saying listen at a certain point here
we're gonna have to think about how we
open up the economy again because we
cannot do this interminably and people
are getting very angry at from yesterday
about this how could Trump say this sort
of stuff how could from talk about
reopening the economy when we haven't
even reached the peak yet and the answer
is you have to talk about it before we
reach the big we have to have some
metric of how we go back to work that
metric has to be established now that
does not mean I've been saying this for
a long time that does not mean a date
certain it doesn't mean he say we're all
going back to work Martin may first we
don't have the data for that yet what we
do need is a formula from the federal
government for exactly what what boxes
need to be checked so that we can start
going back to work we're gonna get to
this in just one second you know the
strategy of how we go back to work and
how we make all of this happen but first
if you haven't had a chance to see some
of our new content we have a new thing
it's called all-access live you should
head on over to daily wire comm and
check it out Jeremy boring and I kicked
it off last week all the other hosts
have done live streams over at daily
Wired I common I did one on Monday it
was great fun I literally sat here in a
short sleeve shirt I know I exist I wear
them and and played some music for you
all y'all and
and we all hung out together took some
questions it was a lot of fun Alexis
live is a lot more laid-back than our
normal programming it's less focused on
bringing you news and information we're
not just hanging out with you at the end
of a long day and hanging out together
since we are all locked up in our homes
at this point I think it's coming from a
positive heartfelt place and I think
everybody is enjoying it a lot the
show's intended for all access members
in the long term but right now during
the national emergency and this time of
sort of social isolation we've opened it
up to all of our members and in doing so
we've accelerated the launch so please
let us know what you think of it if
you're around at 8 p.m. Eastern 5:00
p.m. Pacific tonight join us on all
access live over at daily wired comes we
know who's hosting it tonight it was
Noah's last night so I assume that it's
you
I guess Matt Walsh is doing an
all-access live tonight scene to hang
out with Matt and get your morose and
depressing answers from from Matt Walsh
as well as religiously strict answers
from Matt Walsh tonight over at daily
wire.com you should join us it really is
a party at least as much of my party as
it can be in the midst of a global
pandemic come hang out with us over it
daily we're comin we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
okay so president Trump yesterday was
getting in it was was getting himself in
suppose at hot water for suggesting we
have to reopen the economy at some point
now listen President Trump says um
President Trump
uses his Twitter in I just repeat very
very dumb ways okay the president today
tweeted this ad about Mitt Romney Mitt
Romney tested negative for coronavirus
and Trump tweeted out this is really
great news I'm so happy I can barely
speak he may have been a terrible
presidential candidate and an even worse
US senator but he is here right now and
I like him a lot really the really
presidential leadership right there
the sound solid stuff like shut down the
Twitter shut it down okay it's not
hopeful it's just not helpful at all but
with that said did President Trump to
anything wrong when he suggested that he
wants us to go back to work that he that
he would like to see an end to this
thing no I mean I think that Dad that
makes perfect sense
President Trump said yesterday that
shutting everything down is one of the
most difficult decisions he's ever made
well it should be it's that it's the
most consequential economic decision in
the history of mankind so I would assume
it's one of most difficult decisions
that are made here as president Trump
yesterday a few people walk into the
Oval Office say sir we have to close up
the country and the Saudis I said what
do you know that mr. president must have
been a very difficult thing to accept
one of the most difficult decisions I've
ever made because I knew that when you
do it as soon as you do it you're gonna
drop I mean they're talking about 20 or
25 points of GDP nobody's ever heard of
25 points if we went down a point that's
a big deal now all of a sudden you're
basically turning off the country I said
this has never been done before what are
you talking about
okay and then president from says that
he would love to be ready to go by
Easter and this was the one that got
everybody crazy is that he said by
Easter I would love to see us back out
in in and working that would be by April
12th now some people were saying he's
saying a date certain it's a date listen
so I think it's smart for the president
to actually put a date on the calendar I
don't think it's actually smart for the
president to do that because either we
hit the date or we don't hit the date if
we don't hit the date then the
suggestion is gonna be the Trump blew it
and if we do
hit the day then the suggestion is gonna
be the Trump accelerated beyond what the
evidence showed you know saying that
this is a matter of weeks not months
which you said on Monday I thought I was
all in favor of that him saying weeks
not months I think is good him saying a
date certain
or at least suggesting even a day it
really isn't a date certain but
suggesting a date I think sets up in an
unrealistic expectation but here was
President Trump saying he'd love to be
ready to go by Easter I'd love to have
it open by Easter okay I would have it
open by Easter I well I will tell you
that right now I would love to have that
it's such an important day for other
reasons but I'll make it an important
day for this too I would love to have
the country opened up and just raring to
go by Easter okay he was getting all
sorts of flack for this and he was asked
specifically about you know whether this
is realistic or not and it was more
about like what he feels because
president from just says things and he
said but when he says that we could lose
more people to a recession than to
coronavirus and people lose their minds
about this he says we could see mass
suicides we could see the renewed FBI
opioid epidemic and there's you know
some evidence to show that depressed
economic circumstances do lead to poorer
life outcomes so when President Trump
says we'll lose more people to the
recession than the coronavirus we don't
know well honestly what we don't but to
pretend that there are not real life
consequences to the greatest economic
downturn in the history of mankind would
be obviously foolhardy here was Trump
saying obviously we're gonna need to
come up with a solution here we'll lose
otherwise we're gonna lose a lot of
people on the other hand to it to a
failing economy you're gonna lose a
number of people to the flu but you're
gonna lose more people by putting a
country into a massive recession or
depression either illness people you're
gonna have suicides by the thousands
you're gonna have all sorts of things
happen you're gonna have instability you
can't just come in and say let's close
up the United States of America the
biggest the most successful country in
the world by far okay so these are
serious concerns dr. Anthony foul has
asked about this and he said like what's
the evidence for Easter and foul she
gave the right answer which is we don't
have evidence for Easter he's just being
aspirational which is obviously true
right Trump is just saying I'd love to
have it open by Easter but from says a
lot of stuff here is dr. Anthony foul
she sort of softening the blow a little
it's a back and forth that the president
clearly listens I mean he has this
aspirational goal of hoping that we
might be able to do it by a certain date
we talked him about that we say we need
to be flexible he realizes that and he
accepts that I mean he doesn't want to
give up his aspirational goal but he's
flexible enough to say okay let's look
at it on a day-by-day basis we say and
we will give him data to inform the
decision by the way what foutch he is
saying right there gives the lie to the
entire Democratic line which the Trump
leadership Trump's leadership is
terrible and that he is unsafe Joe Biden
has been pitching that right Joe Biden
can't string a sentence together at this
point Joe Biden yesterday he was on TV
saying that Trump should start listening
to the experts and stop talking there is
foul Qi literally saying he's listening
to us and he is and he is trying to give
hope to the American people and here is
Joe Biden saying he should listen to the
experts
peanut butter he should stop talking
they start to listen to the medical
experts you talk about having an
economic crisis you want an economic
crisis let watch this spike watch the
number of dead go up watch the number of
people who in fact connect with this
virus when you're gonna be able to open
the economy look we all want the economy
open as rapidly as possible the way to
do that is let's take care of the
medical side of this immediately one of
the things he's not responsible for the
coronavirus but he's responsible for the
delay in taking the actions that need to
be taken as far back as January okay
well here's the bottom line he's dealing
with all that and we should try and set
up before now the next responsibility of
the government obviously is to set up
that formula how many beds do we need
how many ventilators we're only gonna
know that once we have better data via
testing when are those tests gonna be
available according to according to dr.
Scott Gottlieb over the former FDA
Commissioner we should have 75,000 tests
a day ready to go by the end of next
week which is going to make a rather
large difference in terms of our data by
the way when when you talk about
expertise Joe Biden you should at least
know where to COFF and when you're
corrected about where to COFF you should
take it seriously Joe Biden was on Jake
Tapper yesterday and he coughed into his
hand and Jake Tapper had to correct him
on the proper coughing technique
I've not talked to any individual excuse
me you know you're supposed to coffin to
your elbow I don't know sir thoughts I
learned that actually covering your
white house you know actually actually
that's true but fortunately I'm alone in
my home but that's okay all right I
agree you're right
you should just it's kind of old school
to do with your hand do it into the URL
but you're supposed to do it okay there
he is listening to the experts Joe Biden
okay meanwhile right now what we are
finding is that the so the expectation
the beginning of the day is that the
house was simply going to pass this
thing rather the house was going to pass
this this bipartisan bill that was
negotiated by the Democrats it was Chuck
Schumer was the lead negotiator on it
over the weekend Nancy Pelosi ain't
gonna vote on it today she's gonna hold
it up another day brilliant negotiation
strategy from Nancy Pelosi we're in the
middle of a global pandemic and an
economic meltdown in which literally
millions of people are gonna lose their
job and Nancy Pelosi is holding this
thing up again today that is the latest
news seriously I mean I don't know what
she thinks her strategy here is also
apparently Andrew Cuomo was ripping into
the Senate bill he said it was a drop in
the bucket compared to the need and and
he's ripping Schumer by implication the
house will not pass the coronavirus bill
today according to Chad a program who is
reporting over at fox news already
gambled in gaveled out of pro forma
session senior sources say House will
not meet again later today acting with
all the alacrity necessary in the midst
of a global pandemic I mean it's just
unbelievable playing politics at this
point playing politics just insane
insane so something will pass in the
next couple of days but everybody should
keep in mind you know when we go through
the list of errors that happen in the
midst of all of this the list of
political failures that happen in the
midst of all this yes the Trump
administration is gonna come in for some
criticism over lack of testing and
ventilator production early on by the
way if Trump had said we need a global
lock down in January Democrats would
have said that he's an actual dictator
so let's just keep that in mind
right the counterfactual where Trump
says we need to ramp up production and
we need to shut everything down go home
for two weeks does anyone really think
that in the beginning of February when
all the media were proclaiming that this
was not actually that river threat
including the folks over at voxcom do
you think anybody would've gone along
with that with that said that was a
failure now we
experiencing the failure that attends to
a Democratic Party that is much more
driven by pleasing its radical base on
environmental issues than on saving the
economy okay time for a thing that I
like and then we'll do a quick thing
that I hate so things that I like as you
all know we're really grateful for our
sponsors here over at Daley wire.com one
of our chief sponsors is Birch gold if
ever there has been a time to think
about diversify into gold now might be
the time Goldman Sachs is actually
encouraging people to diversify into
gold I had a chance to sit down late
last week with a with a spokesperson for
Birch gold and here is what that sounded
like folks today four things I like one
of the things that I like are our
sponsors here at the Benton Schapiro
show obviously in chaotic times who rely
a lot on our sponsors and we ask that
you patronize our sponsors but the folks
over at Birch gold group are some of the
most trustworthy people I know and they
are very trustworthy obviously when it
comes to diversification and putting
some of your money into precious metals
joining us online is Phillip Patrick
precious metals specialist for Birch
gold group Phil thank so much for
joining the show really appreciate it
thank you for having me Ben thank you so
let's start off with a quick market
analysis obviously the coronavirus is
absolutely tank to the market that's not
a shock it's an exogenous shock to the
market plus the governments around the
world are basically shutting down nearly
every business people are being told to
stay home but are their underlying
market fundamentals that we should have
been concerned about even before this
with regard to the economy the answer is
yes and you and I I've discussed this I
think in the past but you know that the
issues that we have today in the markets
I think certainly predate the
coronavirus we've been at the longest
bull run in market history and we've
been there for really the last ten
months or so so I think timing for a
while now has suggested Corrections on
the cards and the bubble really I would
say has been fueled over the last 11
years really by policy right low
interest rates pumping money through the
markets through quantitative easing
corporate buybacks at the highest levels
in in in history what I will say about
the coronavirus is look if you'd asked
me at the beginning of the year when I
felt the markets would correct my
feeling was later in the year right
third or fourth quarter what I think
it's done is is acted as as a Black Swan
if
you will this unforeseen event and
essentially become a catalyst I think
it's pulled the time frames forward and
I think ultimately exacerbated the issue
and for me this is really really
important I think what's happened is
we've turned from a financial crisis to
an economic crisis 2008 was clearly a
financial crisis right and what happened
the government stimulated right pumped
money through the markets dropped
interest rates and it ultimately pulled
us out we've tried that today I mean the
Fed just pumped a ton of money through
the markets biggest rate cut since 2008
it had no effect the market kept
spiraling down this has really become an
economic crisis and I think it's fairly
obvious right you left your house in in
2008 people were spending they were in
bars and coffee shops and restaurants
today it's a ghost town here in the
United States and globally that
significantly exacerbates the issue
right it millions of jobs are at risk
people not spending it creates a major
major issue missing with Phil Patrick
title is precious metals specialist for
Birch gold group so Phil where do you
think stocks go from here there's sort
of a consensus that the bottom has not
been found yet although who the hell
knows because it is I thought the bottom
was at 23,000 now it's been dropping
below 20,000 bouncing around 1,500 2,000
points a day it's really difficult to
tell where the bottom of the market is
and tell people to buy stock in a
volatile market is always a difficult
thing so where do you think the stock
market is going yeah I mean you hit the
nail on the head it's it's very very
difficult to predict because quite
frankly we haven't been in this
territory at least for a hundred years I
would say so
it's tough to predict what I can say is
just looking at things this could
potentially be the tip of the iceberg we
look at the Oh 8 crash right back then
at its high point the Dow dropped 50%
we're down today roughly from from the
highs about 30% so what that tells me is
this this matches what we saw back in
2008 there's potentially another 20%
downside my concern however is this
could be and we sort of address this a
moment ago but it could be much much
worse than 2008 and something
look out and I think I've mentioned
before on the show is cyclically
adjusted p/e ratios price-to-earnings
ratios even with the downside that we've
seen the the cyclically adjusted price
to earnings ratios roughly about 23
today the historical average sits at
about 16 what that means is if we just
go to an average multiple in the markets
it puts us down 31% from where we are
today and that's just an average in
theory depending on how bad this gets
how long it takes us to get out of this
it could be much much worse and to
reiterate a point what tools do we have
available we've shot our bullets and
they're not working we don't have the
same tools to pull us out like we did
back in o8 will this be a three to five
year recovery like we saw back in o8
will it be a 25 year recovery like we
saw during the Great Depression the
answer is nobody knows but it doesn't
look good so Phil where do you see gold
prices going from there conversely
obviously as the market sinks a lot of
people have been looking for a safe
haven in gold well where do you see the
gold price going right now I think
pricing is still relatively low right
everyone looks shorter-term but I think
you've got to pull it back gold today in
the $1400 range back in 2011 so after
the Oh a crash gold and silver went on a
bull run and they hit their peaks in
2011 gold back then was trading close to
was in the high mid to high $1,900 range
we're at 1400 today well in the $1400
range silver today in the twelve dollar
range it was 48 dollars back then
the point being we're significantly down
from our all-time highs there's a lot of
value there
Citigroup a one that have predicted gold
could hit 2,000 dollars an ounce as soon
as the next 12 months it feels like
we're heading towards that I think we've
got a long way to go from here so with
all the cows what exactly have been the
last two weeks it at Birch Goldsboro Bay
I have to imagine that it's been rather
chaotic yeah that's that's the perfect
word chaotic to say the least look as a
company given the climate we've had our
best month on record and we're already
there and we're
even at the end of the month just from
from an individual standpoint it's
absolutely crazy the ones I feel sorry
for the the processes in our IRA
Department they're nonstop and actually
we're hitting the other end fidelity
Charles who are the companies that we're
helping to roll funds over from their
hole times are an hour and a half right
now so I think a lot of people are sort
of I think it's craziness all over it's
not just ask the big institutions are
getting here people are trying to pull
their money out and it's it's it's rough
but I can't complain well really
appreciate your time Philip Patrick
birch and gold groupies precious metals
and specialists as you know Birch gold
is a sponsor of the program make no
bones about that they're the people I
would trust with precious metals
investing I'm not somebody who says
liquidate all of your stock holdings but
if you got money lying around you're
looking to invest you would want to
diversify it would have been good to do
so you know a couple of months ago texts
been to 47 47 47 today see how simple
and straightforward these moves can be
for you get all of your questions
answered Phil thanks so much for your
time thank you for having me things been
alrighty so we have run out of time on
today's show but we'll be back here a
little bit later today with two
additional hours of content including
apparently the LA sheriff has ordered
gun stores closed as non-essential
businesses while they're releasing
people from jail so good news happening
out there great governance happening
across the country we'll bring you all
of the updates a little bit later today
over two additional hours of content if
not then we will see you here tomorrow
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling assistant director Pavel
Whitehouse key technical producer Austin
Stephens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SCI events audio
is mixed by Mike Cora Mina hair and
makeup is by Nika Geneva the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20 the market
jumps to thousand points scientific
studies show coronavirus hope on the
horizon a new drug is helping patients
and president Trump is calling for
America to reopen by Easter Sunday we
will examine all the excellent news
after weeks of apocalyptic headlines
then the Trump administration announces
the largest stimulus package in American
history
Bernie refuses to drop out of the race
and sleepy Joe somehow manages to
deteriorate even further on national
television check it out on the Michael
Nolt show
[Music]